but let's presume you really need a
raster image because some things just
can't be represented well by a vector
drawing
this is a 21 megapixel photo of my cat
obviously you probably really don't need
that resolution pushed down to a mobile
device if i'm just writing a blog post
about my cat this is a four megabyte
image after all so what should we do
with this image to deliver it to
different devices
your first option is to kind of cheat
you can always deliver a high resolution
but low quality encoding
everywhere that is give the same image
to all devices that's a higher
resolution a 2x image for example
but lower the quality in the jpeg
encoder to 20 rather than 90.
this typically can result in a 2x image
that will look better than an
uncompressed 1x image
and you'll notice at the same time it
actually has a smaller file size using
this technique will work well in many
cases but it does come at a cost the
browser also needs to spend some time
decompressing the image and on a 1x
device it needs to scale the image by 50
percent to fit it into the available
pixels you can also start to see some
color banding in some gradients and
using this approach
sure lower pixel count devices will get
a bigger image than they need but not
too much more data since it's low
quality and higher pixel count devices
will get the right size although they
will get a slightly lower quality image
than they would normally want
this option isn't great but it's
definitely better than only serving low
pixel count art or serving only high
pixel count art to all devices